- Yo, yo, yo, I'm Moshow The Cat Rapper.
♪ I got a bunch a cats ♪
♪ Roll it back, get it
back, cats on my lap ♪
♪ Got cats on the mat ♪
♪ Clippin' cats on my mat ♪
♪ Ugh, Austin, I be at, ugh ♪
So I got five cats, DJ
Ravioli, Queen Sushi,
Tali the Lover, the mighty
Megamam, and Black $avage,
and the S is a dollar sign.
They have a lot of cat clothes, you know,
popped collar stuff,
a favorite color's pink,
so we a lotta pretty in pink photo shoots
and, yeah, they got
clothes, clothes for days.
Yeah, they're fresher than me, you know?
(laughs)
I felt more drawn to a sphinx
because I felt like we had a connection.
You know, they're bald, I'm
bald, I don't have any hair,
so it just felt just right
and I wanted to show people
that, hey, sphinx are awesome too
and the reason why I adopted Black $avage
is because black cats are
the least to be adopted
due to stereotypes,
people say 'cause of how movies
show them, they're bad luck.
If you ever get a chance,
please adopt a cat,
but if really got a really big heart,
adopt a black cat as well.
(percussive electronic music)
Don't force the love.
Cats choose you.
If you have a great personality
and you're just oozing with love,
the cat will recognize that
and the cat will find you.
(percussive electronic music)
Heck yeah.
(woman laughs)
Yeah.
I ain't done, yeah,
it's just the beginning.
(laughs)
For the cat game, pullin' up on y'all.
Mogame, cat world.
(percussive electronic music)
- [Man] Hey guys, we're
- [All] Pero Like!
- Did you know it's
Hispanic Heritage Month?
(speaking foreign language)
- For more Latino content:
- Subscribe here!